[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
is the foundation unfairly using ahmad
arbore's name his mother
calling on them to stop and filing a
lawsuit against authorities alleging a
cover-up in her son's death
i want to get justice for am i a social
worker sues the chicago police
department
after officers wrongfully detain her in
a botched raid why angina youngs has
officers humiliated her
in her own home
turn to a defendant x to try to prove he
murdered his wife
then hid her body did he ever tell you
you'd never get out of there alive
yes law and crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a georgia mother anguished by the loss
of her son is taking her grief to court
filing a lawsuit against defendants
police and prosecutors
first people i lost to my my family and
i
and then we had to go out and actually
fight
to get some attention to get a rest
i mean it was a it was 74 days before we
even got a rest
video captured by one of the suspects in
her son's shooting shows three white men
chased down
ahmad arbree aubrey was killed last
february but the suspects were only
arrested after state investigators were
assigned to the case
last may those 74 days seemed like 74
years
wanda cooper jones says she should have
never had to wait those 74 days
before seeing the suspects behind bars
that's why she
and her attorney lee merritt have filed
a federal civil rights lawsuit against
the defendants
glenn county police and two prosecutors
it's a constitutional claim it's the
same claim that the department of
justice is currently looking into
and they've been in contact with my
office and with wanda cooper directly
saying that there is an
ongoing federal investigation into the
behavior of the
legal apparatus of glenn county we're
hoping that there will be criminal
accountability and civil accountability
defendants father gregory mcmichael son
travis mcmichael and neighbor william
brody bryan
are all awaiting trial charged with
murdering arbory they pled not guilty
and maintained the shooting was in
self-defense
gregory mcmichael was a former law
enforcement officer retired from the
local district attorney's office
you know i was the chief investigator
with the da's office okay three years so
i know what you got to do i know
everything you know the lawsuit alleges
district attorney jackie johnson knew
the mcmichaels
instructed officers not to arrest him
then recused herself
it was then handed off to prosecutor
george barnell who also allegedly knew
the mig michaels when he issued a letter
ruling the shooting was justified
initially lynn county deputized those
two gentlemen who
would unfortunately kill them on and
with deputizing them as
as giving them the right to go out and
commit murder you know
my family took a tremendous loss and
someone has to pay for that as well
you know someone has to pay for that but
her claims don't end there
cooper jones and marin also allege a
foundation is using arbore's name
without her consent to raise hundreds of
thousands of dollars
for different charities we're in
agreement with ahmad's father his
attorney ben crump
uh that that we have a strategy in mind
that has to deal specifically with the
the estate and so we went privately to
them and they agreed that they would not
use his name likeness or image
and until yesterday we it became very
clear that they were not willing to do
that instead of having the proper focus
on that lawsuit
and accountability criminal
accountability for the people who had
abused the system and denied this family
due process they went forward with
raising 226
000 uh in ahmad's name using his
likeness and image and claiming to do it
on behalf of the family
um so we're filing another cease and
desist the legal process is slow
we don't want this to be the focus our
focus should be on the federal lawsuit
but we will take
additional legal action to enforce their
prior agreement
that foundation 223 has organized walks
and fundraisers in honor
of the 2.23 mile run aubry took
they previously agreed to not use his
name and deny
any wrongdoing joining us today is
criminal defense attorney bernardo
villalona and terry austin
this federal lawsuit is broad in who
it's going after
terry the foundation that is raising
money in aubrey's name
without the consent of his mother is
this just
poor form or illegal and what can this
lawsuit do to help cooper jones
look i think this is a he said she said
on the one hand you have
wanda cooper jones and she's saying that
she didn't authorize anyone to use his
name and likeness
on the other hand you have a legitimate
non-profit
and they're using 2 23 and they're
raising money they say that their vision
is to see a society that pursues fair
justice and impartial treatment
of black and brown persons they're not
technically using
his name and i do believe that it's
going to be difficult
for wander cooper jones to show that
the foundation is improperly using his
image or likeness
and so it seems to me that i think at
this point based on what i'm seeing all
the money
is technically from the gofundme going
to wanda cooper jones so
i'm not sure she's going to have a claim
as far as that's concerned
it's going to be interesting to see
where that lawsuit goes bernardo the
federal lawsuit screams cover-up
a cover-up involving prosecutors and
police for one of their own
how strong is a lawsuit and could
criminal charges flow from it
so i think it's going to be very
difficult to have criminal charges to
flow
from it because remember in a criminal
case you have to prove the person's
guilt beyond
a reasonable doubt i think it's more
likely that a civil lawsuit will be the
likely avenue
for them to prevail so we know from the
timeline that it took
three prosecutors to finally to finally
look into investigate and hold
accountable and prosecute
those three men that were responsible
for the death of ahmad aubrey
the problem here is from the very
beginning you have the first prosecutor
yes
she excused herself however she excused
herself
after making a determination that they
shouldn't be arrested
the second prosecutor sure he excused
himself but after making a finding that
it was in self-defense that they acted
so that is an issue hopefully we'll see
some kind of charges maybe obstruction
of government
investigation something to that extent
hopefully we'll see that and obviously
keep eyes on that federal lawsuit
still ahead on law and crime daily is
bruce springsteen taking the easy street
on charges of drinking in a national
park but first why chicago woman is
suing police
after a botch raid the horrific body
video camera after the break
welcome back a woman sues the chicago
police department and officers who took
part in a botched raid of her home
more than two years ago anjanet levy
explains what happens
and shows us body cam video of the raid
it was february 2019 chicago police
acting on a tip that someone with a gun
was in a house
stormed into angenette young's home
don't move young was actually getting
ready for bed when police broke down her
door
you got me in here cause i'm naked
and i can't tell you you got the wrong
face okay ma'am
it took more than a year for the city to
release the body-worn camera video
a lawsuit young has filed in cook county
court claims the botched raid violated
her rights
it goes on to say that officers turned
off their body-worn cameras at times to
discuss the situation
and the person they were looking for
andy simpson actually lived next door
we must be the first
to admit our mistakes
the first not because a judge told us
not because we have litigation
but because it's the right thing to do
the suit alleges a cover-up by the city
including mayor lori lightfoot who later
admitted she was notified of the raid
after it happened but said she didn't
recall being told about it
if there are other wrongs that need to
be righted we are going to do just that
we're not going to string these cases
out meanwhile the end of the 40-minute
encounter with angenette young
showed police realizing their error
after talking to
after you know
looking around quickly and
we believe your story we believe not
your story but what you're telling us
okay
lawyers for the city of chicago say they
have not yet been served with that
lawsuit but when they are
they say they will review it and that
they are committed to an
equitable and expeditious resolution to
the case
that will allow anjanette young to heal
for law and crime daily
i'm angenette liebe thanks angenet
here to break down the botched rate in
chicago as criminal defense attorney
bernardo violona and co-host terry
austin
terry young has filed a claim against
police
for pharaoh to independently investigate
and verify the information
from what i know the case law isn't too
kind to her
but it does seem like the city is
willing to work with her do you think
this lawsuit has a chance
you know brian i think obviously you can
sue anyone for anything but i think
to your point the courts have
consistently ruled
that a reliable informant does not have
to be
independently verified all really the
police need to show is that they had a
valid warrant
and the valid warrant was based on
probable cause justifying the search
so you know they have to look at the
totality of the circumstances and i
think
the bottom line here is if the
information was reliable
they knew the informant they'd used them
before there is no requirement that the
information has to be independently
verified she might have a tort claim for
intentional infliction of emotional
distress
she could show that they were reckless
but otherwise i think this case is going
to fail
now bernard the criticism as i hear it
is not just about the raid on young's
home but the aggressive tactics
of the chicago pd relying on weaker
uncorroborated information
you were a former prosecutor and i know
that um i know that as a former
prosecutor bernard has probably looked
into these cases but i want to come back
to you terry
should this be something that changes
drastically
how people raid homes in chicago or
other cities in the united states
well you know i think that you have to
be careful when you are going into
someone's home
this is their home and this is where
they live and they have some expectation
of privacy
and i think you have to be very careful
that you get the address right now
clearly
the city was apologetic and i think that
they will
ultimately work with the individual here
but she definitely was emotionally
distressed and i think they're going to
have to make sure
that they deal with her fairly exactly
you can't just say oops and violate
someone's rights
thanks terry coming up on law and crime
daily what's the worst excuse
you could come up with to get out of
work one man's attempt turns criminal
plus why tiger woods is unlikely to face
any charges in a rollover crash
the incident the sheriff's office is
calling an accident not a crime
next
[Music]
we're back rock legend bruce springsteen
is pleading guilty to one
charge as federal prosecutors agree to
drop drunk driving charges
springsteen appeared virtually in court
on wednesday the 71 year old was facing
three misdemeanors
he was charged last november when he was
stopped while driving in the gateway
national recreation area on the jersey
coast
prosecutors say he declined a field
sobriety test and later blew
a .02 at the ranger station he entered a
guilty plea to the charge
of consuming alcohol in the park where
alcohol is banned
the rock legend admitted to having two
small shots of tequila
the government dropped the charges of
dui and reckless driving
golfing great tiger woods is recovering
from surgery after suffering serious
injuries from a vehicle crash
the los angeles county sheriff's office
says woods was driving downhill
on a winding road tuesday morning in an
area known
as a trouble spot for speeding and
accidents the sheriff's office says
there was no evidence of impairment but
the crash is still under investigation
actor gerard de padua has been charged
with rape and sexual assault in france
prosecutors in paris say the actor is
not in custody but is under judicial
supervision
and must check in with authorities
regularly according to french media
report
death powder have previously said that
he absolutely denies any crime
an arizona man is admitting to going to
extreme length to get out of work
the coolidge police department says
brandon soules faked his own kidnapping
officers responded on february 10 to a
call about a man whose hands were bound
behind his back with a belt
and had a bandana stuffed in his mouth
souls reportedly told the officers that
masked men kidnapped him in front of his
home knocked him unconscious
then dumped him on the street he said it
was because his father hid large sums of
money throughout the desert
but as investigators looked into his
claims they found no
evidence police say he then admitted to
making up the story
as an excuse to get out of his job at a
tire store
he was arrested on charges of making a
false report he pled guilty the next day
and agreed to pay a 550 dollar fine
guess that's one way to get out of work
when we come back inside the wisconsin
courtroom of a nobody murder trial
white prosecutors believe a husband
killed his wife and hit her body
still ahead
welcome back does a wisconsin man have a
history of abusing his wives
prosecutors are using the testimony of
an ex-wife to try to prove he murdered
another
victoria capovich was reported missing
on april 25th 2013.
investigators are unable to find her
remains but arrested her husband james
prokopovic in 2019
after they say he confessed to killing
her prokopovich has since recanted and
says his wife was suicidal
but his first wife says he also
threatened her life
when they were married i don't know how
it started but it ended up with my
daughter
and i put in the bathroom with a shotgun
against her head if she stood in front
of me
were there any threats made to either of
you
yes he was going to shoot us did
you ever indicate that you might leave
him yes
did he ever make threats involving that
yes he said you never get out the door
and these statements and these things
that
happen they occurred while you were
married to him yes
i left with the clothes on my back i
just left i had an opportunity to leave
and i left
at the time that you left were you
afraid of jim and his actions
there was always in the back of my mind
i was afraid of what he was going to do
because he would be
i mean he could be nice one minute and
the next minute he would blow up and
then
be physically and emotionally abusive
on cross the defense pressed there for
details of the alleged gun incident
and their divorce so you got divorced in
8485
when did the gun in occurred right
before the divorce
i don't know when exactly it happened i
don't remember
the year or the date i was still living
in the house it wasn't before the
divorce it was before the divorce
i was still we were living together so
after this gone incident you guys stayed
together
for a period of time we were still
together yes
do you know if it was loaded no i don't
what did he do with the gun after the
incident he went out to the barn with it
do you know if he broke it i don't know
what he did with it
do you know for sure that there was
verbal abuse there was verbal abuse
there was name calling
did you ever respond back to him by name
calling
occasionally yes so those arguments you
had
more than arguments it was a lot of
yelling
you mentioned um that you left with the
clothes on your back you had an
opportunity is that because you
you left with another man i left with
another man that's got nothing to do
with why i left
back to break down the testimony of an
ex-wife is bernardo violona and terry
austin
bernardo the prosecutor came out
swinging with this witness how do you
think the testimony went for them
so the question is going to be what type
of jurors you actually have
are the jurors going to be successful to
actually listening to the ex-wife
are they going to perceive her as a
woman that is born that has something to
take out against her ex-husband
because her husband left her so i'm not
sure how the jury is going to take it
however one thing that did stand out to
me from her testimony is that
she eventually left her ex-husband
however she left her children there with
a person
supposedly who tried to take both of
their lives away
yes something the defense can definitely
press on a little there terry
so far the defense has been countering
most of what the prosecution has thrown
at them
how did the cross cross-examination of
this witness look to you
you know brian once again i think john
deangelo the defense attorney did an
excellent job he's clearly talking to
his client to get additional information
so one of the things that he is okay you
had these injuries you didn't report
them
but even more than that you did not even
show the injuries
to your own children one of the things
he established was the fact okay we know
that he drinks
but did you ever see him drinking to the
point where he got drunk
and frankly she did not because he drank
in a bar
he also established that the name
calling it wasn't just
d'angelo or it wasn't just prokavovic
doing the name calling it was an
argument back and forth so i think he
was able to establish that as well
and you know like bernard just said the
fact that
this separation she left but she left
with another man
and she did leave her children there in
a household and she's claiming that it's
dangerous so
i definitely think d'angelo did a great
job on this cross-examination
and on most of the crossed examinations
now terry and bernardo from what i
understand the prosecution should be
wrapping up their case
uh late uh soon do you think let's start
with uh
terry do you think that the defense is
gonna have to put on a case
uh here to defend their defender client
you know they don't have to here and
most of the time you don't see the
defense
put the defendant on the stand because
clearly he's going to be subject to
cross-examination
and i think had the defense not made so
many points maybe you might consider it
but i think the defense has made the
argument
with the excellent and the pinpoint
cross-examinations that he's done
so far everything else i think can be
done when they do the closing and with
this you know defendant and with this
attorney i think they're going to be
able to do an excellent closing
all right so terry is leaning towards
the defense not putting on a case but
bernarda
is this the type of case that you think
the defendant may need to take the stand
to get them cross that threshold of not
guilty
so the defendant doesn't have to testify
in this case actually the defendant
doesn't have to testify in any case
because they don't have a burden
the prosecution that has the burden of
proving the defendant's guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt
however in this case because of how the
evidence has gone
and the defendant does not have to take
the stand and i wouldn't put him on the
stand because he will be an
open book subject to cross-examination
subject to being questioned about all
these all unanswered questions that the
jury wants to know
so why put him up there where the jury
is going to have some kind of doubt
or be wondering why is he acting or
responding the way that he is
there's no need to put him up and i
wouldn't put him up i agree and i don't
think i
agree with both of you actually i don't
think the defense is going to put on a
case here
i would suspect that the prosecution's
going to end their case
and it might go either straight to the
jury or maybe some sort of technical
argument or some sort of uh they agree
hey let's have this
read to the jury but i expect the jury
will have this case soon and will start
deliberating
bernard terry thank you and thank you
for joining us here at law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you